welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in the Mandalorians season 2 is
one of the few immune things to our
current nightmare
with recent major casting announcements
like rosario dawson as a live action
ahsoka tano Michael Biehn joining the
cast bill bird's character may tell
returning probably to talk some more
smack about Gungans is that why you so
don't want to show your face thanks to
the series innovative stage craft
technology allowing them to project a
vivid backgrounds on giant LED screens
in real time as opposed to you know
shooting everything on location
producers Jon Favreau and a felonious
seem to have rap production on a second
season and might be on schedule to
release the seasons eight episodes in
October ahsoka tano joining the series
in live-action form is a very huge deal
she's one of the biggest characters in
Star Wars at the moment with the current
season of the Clone Wars showing her
journey from her departure from the Jedi
Order through the siege of Mandalore and
her fateful duel with Maul but how will
she tie into the events of the next
season of the Mandalorian and what is
her introduction on this series tell us
about where mando and baby Yoda are
going in season two I got three theories
warn in case you haven't seen the
Mandalorian or the rise of Skywalker
Clone Wars really if you care enough to
whine okay so if you don't know who
ahsoka tano is you're not a true Star
Wars man get out your lucky day Polonia
isn't here he would totally hand you
over to forgoing that out of the way
ahsoka was the Jedi Padawan to Anakin
Skywalker throughout the events of Clone
Wars he was voiced by ashley eckstein
one of the few Star Wars creations
outside the oversight of George Lucas
she grew on fans over the years and in
season five a clone wars she was blamed
for a crime that she did not commit and
the Jedi Council did not have her back
even after her exoneration she parted
ways with the order canal in season
seven she's currently in the lower
levels of Khorasan with the Martez
sisters later this season she'll
participate in this siege of Mandalore
against Maul but both will survive the
siege in the concurrent order 66 to face
each other in a rematch years later in
season two of rebels last we saw ahsoka
in the timeline she appeared with Sabine
ran in the final scene of rebels said
after the Battle of Endor as the two set
off in search for Ezra Bridger
technically we did hear ahsoka once more
in the rise of Skywalker she was one of
the many Jedi voices who reached out to
Rey get back up and to feed Palpatine
really that scene featured a ton of
voices from the animated series
including Freddie Prinze jr. as kanan
jarrus olivia davao as Luminara Unduli
and Jennifer Hale as Aayla Secura but
the fact that these were all voices of
past Jedi you know blew
kobe-wan qui-gon Yoda mace windu it
applied that ahsoka tano was also
deceased at this point if she was in her
mid to late 30s at the end of rebels
could make her around 40 in the
Mandalorian which works with 40 year old
rosario Dawson planar and that would put
her like in her late 60's during the
rise of Skywalker if she were alive but
Dave Bologna tweeted out an illustration
suggesting that like Gandalf
because we assume someone to be dead
doesn't mean that she won't return any
yeah here she is but how exactly will
she collide with Darren mando and baby
Yoda in the next season of the
Mandalorian well the way I see it there
are three general directions they could
go first the dark saber the closing shot
of the Mandalorian sees of one showed
Mothe gideon with the dark saber which
was last seen in rebels in the hands of
boca tong given to her by Sabine to
reunite the Mandalorian people to oppose
the Empire now it seems that some time
after this perhaps during the later
siege of Mandalore with Moff gideon the
Darksaber was taken by gideon but how
getting got the dark saber tells us a
lot about what kind of guy he is if he
just bombed wherever boba I was and took
the corpse that would make him kind of a
weak little [ __ ] and if he were to face
ahsoka in lightsaber combat he would be
screwed by Giancarlo Esposito has hinted
that season two will show us some
lightsaber combat kind of sounds like
the actor got some real sword combat
training suggesting that gideon might
have gotten it from both katana and a
duel making him a truly worthy adversary
of ahsoka setting us up for good spring
vs Claire temple Willard boyfriend Cory
Booker intervened but this first option
could be that ahsoka and Sabine are now
searching for this stolen Darksaber
bringing them on a collision course with
Matt Gideon and therefore with mando and
baby Yoda as well and in this case in
addition to Dawson as ahsoka we would
see a live action Sabine as well that's
fun but what does this tell us about
baby Yoda the answer to the ahsoka
question as all questions are probably
through baby Yoda so we need a theory
for that bundle of fanservice
look in a world where we're all trapped
in our blue dungeons the few times when
you do have to venture out to pick up
some essentials you do not want to waste
time fumbling with a big messy wallet
well thanks to the ridge for sponsoring
this episode
the ridge makes everyday goods to a
standard you don't see every day they
streamline your life by turning the
things you carry like backpacks chargers
and wallets into tools for a better
living the flagship product is the
wallet is launched by Kickstarter in
2013 and now sits in the front pockets
of over half a million men and women my
wallet used to be a Miss I couldn't find
anything in there I would run out of
breath looking for my credit card and
then you know I'd have to like inhale a
bit about side air no fun well this is
their aluminum wallet in the raw color
they do have other colors including some
very flashy Tiki designs it's like it's
strong it has a very cool industrial
chic vibe the ridge is a minimal front
pocket wallet that's designed to
streamline what you carry every day
it has over 30,000 five-star reviews and
is a better way to carry your cash and
cards there's a lifetime warranty if you
love it
three returns if you don't it comes in
titanium carbon fiber aluminum and over
a dozen different styles and colors they
also have great backpacks and travel
bags with RFID blocking pockets and
optional device charging batteries get
10% off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to Ridge
comm slash new rock stars that's ridge
con slash new rock stars and use the
code and new rock stars find the link in
the video's description ok the second
Asoka option is baby oda see some one of
the Mandalorian lifts off with mando on
a search for baby Otis home planet and
race it's still a huge mystery well baby
Yoda even is and whether there are more
of them it's also a mystery what moth
Gideon and Verna Hertzog's characters
wanted with baby Yoda there were some
clues pointing to Kamino and the
possibility that these Imperial
loyalists wanted to clone a new Yoda
similar to the minions of Palpatine who
helps clone him to set up his return and
the rise of Skywalker perhaps ahsoka
will learn of this conspiracy to kidnap
force sensitive younglings for cloning
and set out on a mission of her own to
disrupt it as much as possible to adopt
these poor younglings in a new community
that's different from the Jedi Order
that betrayed her like most of us now
recognize the Jedi Order was a bit
messed up like imagine if you're a
farmer and monks and robes show up and
say your kid is magic and pressure them
and you and - never talking to each
other again in 2020 we can't let a cult
this mission could lead ahsoka to baby
Yoda the biggest target of this Imperial
operation which would also put her in
conflict with mando who might feel that
baby Oda is better off in his hands than
hers
the third option for bringing ahsoka
into this would be the long-lost rebels
character as refriger rebels ended with
ezra in thron getting taken into the
unknown who knows what happened and
Ezra's fate has never been revealed it
seems like he's being saved for
something
Ezra's home planet Lothal is super
important the Star Wars Canon
only contain the mineral that was used
in Death Star construction but it also
contained those mysterious cave
paintings with a cameo by a member of
Yoda species may be owed himself maybe
just another one perhaps in these years
since ahsoka already found Ezra back a
local and now both of these characters
possess the secret to baby Oda's origin
the secret that mando was seeking some
have also been speculating that Ezra
and/or ahsoka could be lost in the world
between worlds that dimension that
enables time travel in the Star Wars
universe and I learn about that the
Mandalorian seems a bit grounded I doubt
it'll expand into the cosmic levels of
Star Wars mythology hey with Michael
Biehn joining the cast my mind has been
busy some are saying he's just been cast
as another bounty hunter that's fun I
would say the Mandalorian has plenty of
bounty hunters a man of beans aged beans
filmography I would love to see this guy
as Grand Admiral Thrawn please like if
Ezra comes in the Mandalorian second
season thron has to as well well comment
down below with how you want ahsoka to
join the Mandalorian second season and a
reminder that you can join our
unfiltered conversation about Star Wars
and Iker and Clone Wars season by
joining their official discord join this
score by becoming a patron of new rock
stars today at patreon.com slash new
rock stars follow me at EA vasa follow
the new rock stars it's described into
rock stars and breakdowns of everything
you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]